Okay.
If I remember correctly,
we stopped with the clocks.
That's true.
Yes.
Good.
Okay.
So one of the things I mentioned was
that the emphasis on the clocks here is
to divide time up and the film makers
emphasize time to tell you in some sense
that we're in the prosaic normal world.
And then in a sense you could say that
when the clock stops,
which you'll see happening,
we,
we move into a different dimension
completely.
And I think I mentioned when we went
through this last time,
that young hypothesized for example,
that there was no time in the collective
unconscious.
And what that means is that there's a
strata of knowing,
I suppose,
that you can think of as outside the
normal stream of individual life.
So it's sort of Super Ordinance and,
and you know,
here's one way to think about it.
So it's pretty obvious that your
personality can transform.
So then you might ask yourself,
well,
what is it that guides that
transformation?
Because in some sense it has to be
outside the thing that's transforming.
And you could say that the,
the place that's outside of that
transformation is this place out of time
and space that you is describing.
And it would be,
it's the same place as a long time ago,
you know,
in a fairy tale which refers to some,
it's like you've been collapsed pass.
That's another way of thinking about it.
Or you can think about it like the
amount of time that passes when you're
asleep as far as your consciousness is
concerned because there's no real sense
of duration.
There is if you,
obviously if you wake up and remember a
dream,
but even dreams take extreme liberties
with time.
I'm sure you've had the experience where
your alarm goes off and the sound is
incorporated into the dream and it's as
if the dream has been going on for a
very long period of time and the alarm
makes sense in the context.
Even though it may have only been
ringing for a few seconds.
Freud observed how much time could deal
dilate and extend in dreams in,
in,
in his book the interpretation of
dreams.
And,
um,
it's a fairly well known phenomena.
So we're in time now.
At this point,
Pinocchio is already got his mouth.
So in principle he's capable to speak.
And so now we're in time and then the
next week we've got the created creature
at this point.
So you might think about that as the,
as the first stage of development.
And the way I look at it with regards to
this movie is that,
you know,
really the next time we see Pinocchio
with Japan.
Oh,
he's off to school.
And so you might say that this is the
moment that ends childhood and that's
the developmental stage we're at.
He's ready to launch himself into the
world or he has at least after this next
scene.
And so that's where we pick them up in
the developmental progress is entry into
the world.
Oh No,
please.
Okay.
So obviously obviously all this is
signifying the transition into
unconscious.
Oh
No.
Well we can sneak in name.
Yeah.
Hi.
Okay.
You are most yolks.
Aw,
come on.
Okay.
So at that point did your pedo expresses
his,
I would say the key element of his value
system as a father or you could say the
key element of his archetipal role as
the good father.
Because of course the father is
separated archetypically into the,
you know,
the positive farther in the negative
[inaudible] and you know,
we've already established the
proposition that your values guide your
perceptions and actions.
And so if it's Japan,
it was fundamental desire is to produce
something real well,
first of all,
we don't know exactly what's what real
means at this point,
but we obviously know that it's not
merely a wooden marinette Marionette,
right?
Because it's contrast it with his
current state and your patio is resigned
to the fact that that's a highly
improbable event.
And so it doesn't necessarily always
occur.
And I would say that's a hint in the
context of the movie of a variety of
things.
But one of them is that it isn't
necessarily the case that people get out
of the marionette stage.
So now I think the thing that makes you
pedal a good father rather than a
terrible father,
a son devouring father,
let's say,
is that he's actually aiming at
developing an autonomous individual.
And so that also means he's aiming to
produce something that will transcend
him and leave him right and that's
capable of operating on it on his own.
It's the very definition of a good
father.
And so that's why he's invested in this
process so far.
That's his goal.
And we know the background,
we know that he's a master carver and it
looks like he's a good guy.
He likes kittens and he likes fish and
he likes to sing and he likes music and
he likes to play and he likes to make
toys.
You know,
those are all,
and his place is comfortable and warm
and inviting and all of those things.
So you know,
there's a very maternal element to it
almost because you know the house is so
cozy and so well kept.
You might ask yourself,
what,
where's the feminine element?
You don't have to wait very long before
you get it.
You had a clue about that.
Now,
and what happens next is that the star
that we saw at the beginning of the
film,
when it was shining over a scene that
looked very much like a,
like a Bethlehem Nativity scene,
that star makes its reappearance.
And we already talked about what a star
might represent,
but we'll go over it very briefly.
You can say,
well,
a star represents a light shining in the
darkness and it's,
it's a symbol of value and purity and
light and illumination and
enlightenment.
And it's also something that transcends
the horizon.
It's above the horizon.
And what happens is that Japan,
no wishes on this star and what he
wishes is that Pinocchio,
he could become a real boy.
And so partly what the film is
indicating through that ritualistic
gesture is that the desire to produce an
individual period or the forces that
have to conspire to produce an
individual cannot be brought about
unless the,
the participants in that process have
elevated their,
their value structure to something
that's beyond what's immediately
evident.
And you might even say secular or,
or,
or earthly or,
I mean,
I know those are all medieval terms,
but,
but that's really the idea that unless
you raise your eyes above normal,
the normal value structure,
you won't be able to participate in this
process.
Now,
you know,
if we make reference back to the story
of the Buddha,
you remember when the angel comes to
visit the Buddha,
he tells us,
he tells a story.
When the angel comes to visit the
Buddhist farther before the Buddha is
born,
he tells him that his son is either
going to be a spiritual leader or a
great king.
And of course the Buddhist farther being
a practical man immediately goes for the
great king theory.
He,
he stuck to earthly desires,
so to speak.
And instead of looking for something
that's transcendent,
and then you might ask yourself,
well,
what constitutes transcendent?
And I would say a variety of things that
we'll explore in the course of the
movie.
But one of the things,
one of the ways that you might
conceptualize it as that it's the
difference between horace and no cyrus
or maybe it's the difference between oh
Cyrus and the union of Horace and earth.
Oh Cyrus,
you can look at it.
I either of those ways.
You remember now when horace goes to
rescue a cyrus,
he has to go back into the underworld
and haul his father out of the depths
and as fathers down,
they're sort of half blind and three
quarters to dad then.
And so the transcendent things,
which is often represented by the eye,
it's,
it's also often wreck.
You see this in Christian symbolism of
fair bit.
So on top of cathedrals in the dome,
often what you'll see is tears of people
and or tiers of angels.
And then at the top you'll either see
God the father or Christ.
And the idea there is that what that
represents.
So let's say the logos,
which is roughly equivalent to horace,
I mean men,
by the way,
I think I probably told you this,
but horace and Christ share many,
many features in common.
You know,
and the notion is,
is that as the methodology of
Christianity developed,
it encapsulated a tremendous amount of
the symbolism and story that was already
present in the Egyptian myths and
incorporated into the,
into the new religion.
So it's not that surprising that they
share a parallels,
but it's very useful to know what the
parallels mean.
There's,
there's a pyramid of power,
there's a hierarchy,
but there's something that stands
outside the hierarchy that fixes the
hierarchy and reshapes it and gives rise
to it.
Well,
that's exactly it.
It fixes it and shapes it and gives rise
to it.
And that that's something that you might
think about as roughly equivalent to the
autonomous individual.
Because at that point you're no longer a
marionette and tell us,
so piaget's highest stage of moral
development,
by the way,
because when children hit that stage,
if they do,
and not all do,
instead of conceiving of morality as
following the rules you conceive of,
morality is following the rules when
that's appropriate,
but adjusting the rules when that's
necessary.
And so you start to view yourself not
only as a follower of the tradition,
let's say,
and not only has something that's
obedient but also as something that has
a say in what the game is going to be
going forward.
And so,
so we're going to surmise that what
Japan is trying to produce since he
isn't producing and Marionette is
something that has a certain amount of
autonomy and thus the,
you know,
the right to interact as an autonomous
being with his,
with his own cultural context.
So now he knows that it's unlikely and
it's also a transcendent wish.
It's sort of outside the dominance
hierarchy because you,
one of the things you could say is,
Oh,
you know,
do you want your child to become an
engineer or a lawyer or a doctor?
Heaven forbid a psychologist.
And in some sense all of that is
irrelevant in relationship to this more
transcendent goal because you can get to
the place of transcendence pretty much
through any disciplinary pathway.
There has to be a disciplinary pathway,
but which one doesn't matter.
What matters is how you conduct yourself
while you're on the disciplinary
pathway.
And so,
you know,
that's an interesting observation too
because it's another thought that
radically undermines the idea of moral
relativism because the idea is while
there can be many disciplinary systems
and so in a sense that borrowers to the
idea of moral relativism,
but there can't be a situation where
there's no disciplinary system.
And you know,
part of that is obviously that human
beings are inculturated creatures and,
and we,
we just cannot exist in the absence of a
disciplinary system.
And you might say we can't exist.
Well in the absence of an optimized
disciplinary system,
so okay,
so your pedo wishes upon this star.
And so he makes,
he makes content contact with something
that's outside the normative world and
well we'll see how that unfolds.
Oh
God.
See Japan,
I was also a little bit of a trickster,
you know,
and you saw that quite repeatedly.
He Makes Pinocchio Fall over.
He kicks his little cat in the rear end
with the puppet.
Now he's making him go open the window.
Like he's playing little tricks all the
time.
No one,
the trickster figure is a very complex
and interesting figure.
Yo describe the trickster as a
psychopomp.
And a psychopomp is someone who mediates
between conscious and unconscious life.
And you can think about that in
relationship to comedians because what
comedians always do and what jokes often
do is revealed truths that no one is
willing to face.
You know,
when the more extreme the comedian,
the more likely they are to transgress
social norms.
Well,
similar caneously making you laugh,
you know,
you can see,
um,
Russell Peters for example,
all he does is tell racist jokes,
you know,
and everyone in the audience is thrilled
about it even though they're all there
in an essence identified with ethnic
group.
You know,
he calls on the Arabs and then he makes
fun of them and they all cheer.
And then he calls on the Indians and
makes fun of them and they all cheer and
the Chinese.
And it's a relief for everyone to get
out of that sphere of the unspeakable
and to,
and it puts everybody in a place of
transcendence because for a moment
they're outside their ethnic identity,
you know,
and they can laugh at themselves as
something that can stand outside of
their own definition.
And so a psychopomp is,
you know,
Freud also talked a fair bit about this
with regards to humor because he said
like slips of the tongue and so forth.
You can also often use them as as
doorways in some sense,
into unconscious contents.
And there's just no doubt about that.
Like if you listen to people very,
very carefully,
you'll make little jokes or little
unconscious slips and you can see if
you're trained to see it.
You can see whole complexes of of often,
you know,
terribly chaotic masses underneath those
sorts of things.
And so their portals in a sense,
into the underworld.
It also is very strange.
You see this when people talk about
their dreams.
I've seen this numerous times where I'll
have someone,
what I do is I have people bring me
their dreams.
If they remember them,
they've written them down,
and then I listened to them once and let
my imagination start playing with them.
And then I go have the person,
they read the dream out loud.
Then I have them go through it sentence
by sentence.
And we,
we do what's essentially free
association from a psychoanalytic
perspective.
You know,
if they talk about uh,
let's say a big box department store,
I might say,
well what,
what first comes to mind when you think
about that?
And they'll have associations and that
sort of lays out the cloud of concepts
that surround that particular image.
And so you keep doing that,
expanding it.
And I'll throw in my associations as
well.
And then we have a discussion about,
you know,
how that might pertain to the current
state of their life.
And it's like,
it's like understanding a book in some
sense or understanding of movie and
often know what's so cool is that if you
really,
really listen to people when they use
words to describe their dreams,
they'll use sentences that mean two
things at the same time and one will
mean it will be a description of the
actual images,
stick content of the dream and at the
same time it will be a description of
what that means and people don't even
notice when they're doing it.
It's so cool.
You have to detach yourself and listen
carefully because if you're following
only the semantics of the conversation,
all you'll see is the reference to the
dream.
But if you remember simultaneously that
the dream pertains to their life,
then you can often,
I wish I had an example for you,
but it's so complex.
I can't,
I actually have dreams recorded from one
client,
about 50 of them in a row all laid out
and we're thinking where we're,
the plan is to put that into book form
and publish it because there isn't
anything like that.
But,
so there are these holes portals through
which you can pass into an unconscious
realm.
And you know this look when you're
having a conversation with people you
know now and then if it's a group
conversation now and then someone will
say something that brings the
conversation to a halt,
right?
You can think of it as a non sequitur
or,
and it's something that a non sequitur
is something that doesn't fall.
And so particularly an unconscious
person who isn't following the trail of
the conversation will pipe up with
something and it brings everyone to a
halt.
And the reason for that is that the
person has just manifested part of their
own unconscious structure at an
inopportune time.
And it's like everyone's on one story
and then bang another one comes to to
join it.
And,
and
that person isn't on the same
wavelength,
so to speak.
There is somewhere else.
And you know,
sometimes you can figure out where they
are and generally speaking,
that is far from pleasant.
So you know,
because as Freud pointed out,
the things that you tend to keep
unconscious are not the most positive
things about you.
At least you don't think so.
There might be lots of positive down
there,
you know,
but you're going to only get to it
through the negative.
So,
so anyways,
a trickster figure who's playing tricks.
The other thing I think I,
I'm not,
I had an experience once when I was
remembering,
I had a memory that from when I was very
young,
my father had this friend who was
Russian,
very good friend who basically served me
as a grandfather.
And I can remember when I'm just very
little,
three or four sitting on the floor on a
rug between this man and my father with
that fireplace going and you know,
farmhouse,
very,
very warm place and a very nice family.
I really enjoyed going there.
And my dad and this gentleman whose name
is Nick Zinner off would sit and talk.
And while he was doing that,
I would take my fist and try to hit his
toes,
you know,
and while he was conversing,
he'd move his toes around.
And so we were playing this game and now
and then my dad would say rather kindly,
you know,
enquire whether or not I was bothering
him and he would say,
no,
it's fine.
And I realized just recently that partly
what he was doing with his tricks was
sharpening me up,
you know,
because I'm trying to hit a moving
target.
Right.
And so he keeps moving it and that means
I have to adjust.
It's a,
it's a goal directed activity training,
you know,
and I know with kids,
the more you,
it's like you're willing in some sense
or carving them.
I think carving is the right word.
The more you interact with them
attentively,
the more sharp and focused they get.
And I can see people walking down the
street with no problem,
who I know were never played with,
cause they sort of lumber along there,
sort of like,
they're like,
don't,
they're not carved and attentive.
They're vagan unshaped and I kind of
think of them as uncarved blocks to
Taoist idea.
Uncarved block is what the world is made
out of before you encounter it.
It couldn't be anything,
but it's nothing.
And so,
and often I've also dealt with children
in places like preschool where I can see
the kids who are sharp and who've been
played with.
They know exactly all you have to do is
look at them with a little bit of a
playful glint and they'll laugh and
they're ready.
Whereas the kids that haven't be played
with there so pathetic know,
I mean this,
I mean this in the literal sense of the
word,
you know,
it's,
it's unbelievably pathetic to see them.
So you'll sit down and the kid lumber
over kind of blindly even and sit right
on your lap,
you know?
And it's basically,
maybe that's a four year old kid,
three year old kid that's like pre
toddler behavior.
That's all they know how to do.
You know?
And so if you have a kid that does that,
just go and sit on a stranger.
They're so desperate for attention,
they can't even help it,
but they're so far behind,
the other kids can't even play with
them.
Cause it's like playing with an
overgrown infant,
you know?
And by that time it's damn near
hopeless.
So,
so you know,
this,
this use of humor and tricks and teasing
and all of that,
I mean it can get mean,
you know,
if it's not bounded properly,
you have to stay on the funny side of,
of Tz.
But if you're constantly playing with
kids,
they sharpen up.
And so that's another thing that
tricksters do.
So I used to steal my daughter's dessert
all the time when she was little,
you know,
right from the time she started sitting
at the table,
which was about probably 10 months older
soul,
you know,
I tried to get her to look out the
window or something like that.
And every time she did it I'd take her
dessert.
And so she got very good at it after a
while she could tell when I was joking
and when there was actually something
there.
And by the time there she was about
three,
I could hardly ever fooled her.
And soon after that she learned a new
trick,
which was if I told her to look at
something,
she grabbed her dessert and then turn
and look at it and put it back down,
you know.
But,
and I could really see this with mark
probably to some degree more with my son
than my daughter because he was an
ornery little rap and very disagreeable,
very disagreeable child.
And um,
I mean in the big five traits sense and
you'd lay down a rule for that kid and
he would worry that thing to death.
You know,
here's the rule.
You have to be embedded date.
Well do you mean seven 59 do you mean
seven 59 and 30 seconds?
What about 79 you know,
seven 59 and 50 seconds or maybe eight
oh two or maybe eight oh five.
And just constant battling right on that
edge to find out exactly where the
contours of the social structure was.
And a lot of that is also playing around
rules.
And if you're ever wondering why your
children are teasing you and bothering
you,
because they will do that nonstop.
It's partly because nothing is more
valuable to a child and adult attention
and partly because they're trying to
figure out who the hell you are.
And so because you're the,
you're the Avatar of the social
structure and so they want to know
everything they possibly can about you.
They're not going to leave you alone.
So well,
that's all comment on the utility of the
trickster.
You know,
the other thing that tricks your
daughters sometimes from a
methodological point of view is trick
you into behaving properly,
you know,
with humor or something like that.
And that's partly why the trickster is a
mediator between the normal domain of
consciousness in the sort of
transcendent archetypal realm.
So,
oh,
stop.
First Star.
I see.
Which
I think
my thing of Pinocchio,
just thing
very loving.
Okay.
So there was a couple of interesting
things that happened there.
You know,
first you see that cuts back to the
cricket.
So it's clearly that he's,
uh,
he's clearly involved in this and he's
listening to see what's happening.
So,
and then of course he comments that
that's not a practical,
that's not,
it's not practical.
That's in,
in some sense that's exactly right
because practical basically means
instruction and how to climb the
particular hierarchy.
You know,
impractical means no instruction
whatsoever.
But there's a transcendent practicality,
which is more like how to operate in
this space between hierarchies.
And so that's,
that's more than practical.
You could think about it as metta
practical.
And I think really the purpose of most
religious ed education when it's still
grounded in its original materials so to
speak,
is to catalyze this Mehta identity.
You know,
it's sophisticated being,
Yup.
Can you give me,
well,
I would say,
you know,
the best example I know is the story of
Horus.
But if you want to relate it to your own
consciousness,
you know,
so here's an example.
Wait,
wait,
sorry we're late.
No,
no.
It's more than that.
It's outside of principles because
principals have already been laid down
as rules,
but rules have their problems.
You know,
because once you formulate something
in a static manner,
you limit the number of situations that
it can apply to.
You know,
cause we couldn't say,
well don't never kill another human
being.
Well,
that's a pretty good rule of thumb.
But there are situations where it's not
tenable.
There has to be something that operates
outside of the rule framework that
that's,
that extracts out the spirit of the
rules.
That's a way of thinking about it.
Universal.
Well that's,
that is what this is.
But I wouldn't call it a principle,
I would call it more of,
it's more like a process and the process
is tightly aligned with paying
attention.
Let me give you an example.
You're playing a musical piece.
Okay?
Now when you're practicing that piece,
what you're doing is building a motor
hierarchy.
You know,
you start,
it's very difficult to do it.
You,
you practice and practice and you're
automating these motor routines and
you're driving the action from your
whole cortex to the left hemisphere and
then backwards and making these little
micro machines that are specialized for
these operations.
But let's say you make a mistake while
you attend to that,
you know,
so that's a,
that's a trigger of error.
And then what you do is slow down and
analyze the motor programs that you've
already programmed and you see where the
error is and then you correct it slowly
and practice the correction that
practice the correction and practice the
correction.
So what you're doing in a sense is
tuning the hierarchy,
the automated hierarchy.
And the thing that I'm talking about is
the thing that pays attention to error.
And that might be the best way of of
conceptualizing it.
There's something that pays attention to
error or there can be,
and it's also the thing that moves up
and down hierarchies and tries to find
the optimal level of analysis for
correction and then does the correction.
And sometimes that can be minimal,
you know,
when it's down at the real,
details of motor output.
But sometimes it can be revolutionary.
Now I can tell you a couple of
mythological rifts on that.
So Horace is represented.
Remember Marta?
Marta is represented mostly as the force
that that goes into combat with ty Mac.
So chaos.
But that's fine.
So chaos is what emerges.
You know,
when the social order is disruptive
threat.
In a minor way.
He also organize the society.
It comes up at the top because you
remember before he's willing to go fight
time mad.
He forces all the gods to meet,
to organize themselves and to proclaim
him king of the hierarchy.
So He's two things.
He's the principal at the top or the
process at the top of the hierarchy,
eyes and mouth,
and he's the determiner of destiny's,
which is explicitly stated in the
Mesopotamian myth.
And as that thing,
his primary role is to go and combat
chaos.
Okay.
By the time the Egyptians come along,
there's two major problems that are
emerging as sort of architectural.
I would say one is while there's still
the underworld to deal with,
that's chaos,
but the other one is the rot of previous
structures and that's Cyrus and seth,
right?
Because you could,
you could think of,
oh,
cyrus is only protective.
You're culture is functioning.
It's protecting him for the terrible
element of Mother Nature and it's
working perfectly.
But the problem is it doesn't work
perfectly for two reasons.
One is it just decays with time because
yesterday's solutions are not
necessarily appropriate.
Today's circumstance and it sped along
by people's unwillingness to attend to
errors and correct them refusal to do
that,
and that's refusal to make the proper
sacrifices.
So that's what gets cane in trouble.
For example,
he will not make the right sacrifices.
Somebody kindly sent me another
translation of Gods gods conversation
with Cain when Cain goes to complain
about the nature of being,
and God basically tells him straight out
that if he's,
if things aren't going well for him,
it's his fault.
And so it lays explicit stress on the
idea that they're,
part of the reason that things are going
wrong for cane is that he's,
he's not doing the right thing.
It's not only the arbitrary decision of
God.
So,
so the thing,
the thing that stands above in some
sense is the thing that corrects errors
or you could eat,
you could say,
you could say that in a slightly
different manner because one of the
things that I've,
I've been trying to figure out in some
sense what might constitute the highest
virtue.
And I don't think it's an answerable
question actually,
because there there's an interdependent,
there's an interdependence of virtues.
I think the primary decision that people
make is whether or not you want to make
being better or worse.
That's,
that's the pinnacle of any of any
particularized hierarchy.
So you're always making that decision
better works better or worse,
better or worse.
If you want to make it better,
then you're the optimal tool you have is
true.
And then if you're in that hierarchy,
that thing that stands above it,
the eye,
let's say,
or the transcendent feature is the thing
that attends to error and repairs.
And if you squelch that,
which is exactly what happened in the
Soviet Union,
then the whole bloody system starts to
shake.
You know,
the psyche because people have to
falsify their experience constantly,
never updating it,
never repairing it.
And then the whole bloody system starts
to oscillate too because you can't voice
your detection of error.
You know,
in part of the utility of free speech,
and this is precisely utility of free
speech,
is that people get to voice their error
detection.
Now,
they might be wrong.
You know,
everybody has to figure that out.
But if you stop people from objecting,
then the system can't correct itself and
it will become corrupt because it does
that.
But it'll just careen off the path.
So what Japan was doing,
what he's trying to do in generating a
genuine individual is to produce an
entity that's related to the divine,
hence the star,
but whose function is to,
to,
to be socialized by the hierarchy,
but then to repair it.
Now that's manifested most particularly
in this movie on a couple of levels.
First of all,
Pinocchio has to make minor course
corrections.
He,
he makes mistakes and gets off the path
and has to return.
So that alters his character.
And sometimes,
sometimes in a way that's a mixed
blessing to say the leaks,
you know,
cause he's damaged by deviation from the
path.
But so that's one part of
transformation.
But this movie takes the transformation
all the way to its logical conclusion.
Because in order for Pinocchio to
completely catalyze his transformation
into an autonomous individual,
he has to go to the very depths,
right in the bottom of the underworld to
the most monstrous thing.
And it's from that rescues his father.
It's the same story as the story of o
Cyrusone Horace.
And there's an idea there,
here,
here's,
here's the ideas.
You will not understand the value of
your culture until you face the thing
you're most afraid of.
And that's what this story means.
And it's partly because you can't tell
what the utility of the ideas are until
you experienced a situation where the
most profound ideas become necessary.
And that won't happen unless you face
something terrible.
So,
okay,
no,
you know,
what the movie is doing is constantly
hinting at what that transcend that and
figure is,
you know,
and,
and I would say what human beings have
been doing ever since we became self
conscious was attempting to define the
parameters of ideal Ba.
So,
and a religious story.
Buddhism and Christianity are very
intent on specifying the nature of ideal
Ba.
And the reason they're doing that,
it's because they,
they match ideal being against
mortality.
And they say,
look,
we faced this terrible problem.
It's the one outlined in the fall.
He's the one outlined in the story of
the Buddhist,
you know,
inability to go home.
Again,
it's the same idea.
There's a mode of being that allows
people to live properly and for society
to be maintained in the face of that.
The question is what's
that ideal mode of being?
And the answer is we'd been trying to
figure that out individually and
collectively ever since history began.
And what we have as a record of that is
the trail of profound religious ideas
that,
that you know,
that we're,
that we're leaving behind us as we move
through time.
But you can't understand why those are
useful until they become necessary.
So you don't go deep enough,
you don't go deep enough into the
underworld,
you know.
So for example,
your conception of good is pretty
unsophisticated and naive until you know
what its opposite is.
You know,
and I've encountered a fair bit of that,
I would say in my psychotherapeutic
practice because a lot of the problems
that I attempted to solve that are
rooted in individual and then also in
the family because there's almost no
barrier between those two things.
You know,
it's like a trip.
It's like Donald Tastes,
inferno,
you start at one level of hell.
That's really not too bad.
It's sort of like vacation hell.
And then you know,
and that's like the outside circle in,
in Dante's inferno where the ancient
philosophers were,
you know,
they weren't Christian.
So as far as the Catholics were
concerned,
they weren't going to be in paradise,
but they were starting about the Chief
Club Med version of hell.
And then Dante takes you down layer by
layer to the ultimate hell that's at the
bottom.
And in that hell in Dante is poem.
That's where the betrayers are.
And that's also where Satan,
if I remember correctly,
sometimes I get this confused with
paradise lost.
That's where Satan,
who's the archetipal figure of evil is
lodged and immobile,
immobilized right at the center.
And so the journey is down to the lowest
level into the underworld to encounter
the archetype of evil.
And it's at that point that religious
stories start to become the values that
are put forth in religious stories start
to become crucially necessary cause
they're the only thing you have that can
fortify you against that level of
catastrophe.
So,
and you know,
so partly what this developmental
process is supposed to be accomplishing
is the production of a personality
that's capable of doing that.
So,
you know,
part of partly I figured this out in
part because I was,
I did a lot of meditation on the things
that I read about,
about the concentration camps in Germany
and in the Soviet Union,
but,
but things that were worse than that
because there are things that have
happened in the world that are far worse
than that.
I think the worst things I ever found
were the actions of unit.
I don't remember one 72 it was a
Japanese unit that went into China.
It's like,
it's just,
it's so terrible.
It's traumatizing to read,
you know?
And partly what I was doing when I was
going through that material was trying
to imagine myself as the person who did
that.
And that's,
that's no game.
You know,
like if you're really imagining it
because you have to put yourself in the
place where you could do that.
And that's a terrible thing to realize
that you could do that,
to realize that that's part of your
character.
And until you realize that you don't
have enough motivation to mess with any
ideas that are actually profound,
it's just too difficult and unnecessary.
So well.
So we'll continue with this.
Great.
Okay,
so,
so one of the things that,
that appears to be the case,
you know,
when you have two hemispheres,
okay?
The reason for that appears to be that
you need to neural networks in order to
negotiate the world,
you need one to produce stable warbles
of reality and you need another two.
Identify deviations from that and then
feed the process deviation information
slowly into the system that imposes a
stable view.
Because you know,
I,
I'm sorry I don't have the details of
this quite right,
but if you train a neural network,
for example,
to identify birds,
and so it learns how to do that and to
identify fish and it learns how to do
that and you feed it a penguin,
then all birds become fish.
What happens is the anomaly blows the
category structure.
And so the category structure now ranges
from fish to birth.
And so in order to prevent that,
you need a separate system that deals
with exceptions.
Now that's what we have in our right and
left hemispheres roughly speaking.
And what the right hemisphere does is
identify anomalies and start to
formulate a theory around it.
That's a fantasy essentially.
And then when you were asleep at night,
while you're dreaming,
the right hemisphere is communicating
with the left hemisphere,
the left hemisphere is categorical
structures loosen up and you can
experience that in the dream because
things become somewhat irrational,
right?
And then the brain plays with how it
might recategorize information in the
least damaging fashion in order to
incorporate this new information.
And a lot of that's a dream.
So that's what's happening at night.
Your brain is basically updating itself
and it's a very important process.
If you deprive people of dream sleep,
they become psychotic and quite quickly.
So it's a nontrivial necessity.
So
now this,
this is complicated so that we've got
this bug now and he's the only thing
that's awake and he's being driven mad
by time.
That's what's happening here.
And you'll see his eyes start to move
independently.
And that's a very common cartoon
representation of insanity.
And it's quite interesting because one
of the things that you see in
schizophrenia is eye movements that are
unconscious.
And so it's as if you've got voluntary I
direction fields at the front of your
brain and involuntary ones at the base
of your brain.
And when you're dreaming,
the involuntary ones are the ones that
are in control.
And when you track a moving object,
that's also the involuntary one.
So you can,
you can experience this.
So if you put your finger up here and
track that,
it's no problem.
Smooth vision.
Okay,
now try to do that.
Try to move your eyes that smoothly
without having that thing to track.
Try it.
So you do this first,
don't move your head,
but just track it.
You'll see it and feel your eyes moving
smoothly.
Okay?
Now put your finger down.
Now try to move your eyes that smoothly
and you can't do it.
You go Chu,
Chu,
and it's partly because the old eye
movement system is more sophisticated
than the new eye movement system.
One of the things you see in
schizophrenia is that the person is
using voluntary eye movements,
but there's emergent grip of control
over the eye movements by these archaic
parts of the brain.
And you could think about that as the
emergence of the dream up into waking
consciousness and that's associated with
the schizophrenia symptomatology.
So okay,
so anyways,
back to this bug.
Okay,
so what is the bug do while we know he's
associated with a star,
we know he's a tramp and we've already
covered the possibility that he stands
for those things that bug you.
Now,
one of the things that I would suggest
is that,
and this is union idea,
is that those things that bug you are
the portals both to the unconscious
world or to the underworld and also the
portal to further development.
So,
and it's part of an error detection
system.
So let's say you walk into your house
and you think,
Jesus,
that really bugs me at why does it bug
you?
Well it's because your anomaly detection
system is saying,
look,
there's something out of kilter here.
This territory is not property mapped or
not property groomed.
You know,
cause you can map,
you can make your map accurate by
changing the map or changing the
territory either way.
And sometimes the thing to do is change
the territory.
You don't remap your bedroom when it's
messy,
you clean it up so that it matches the
map.
And so lots of times you walk into your
house and something bugs you and it's
like,
that's an anomaly detection.
And you might say,
it really bugs me.
Well or you'll say it really bugs me
when my mother does that.
It's like,
yeah,
go,
you go investigate that.
And see where you get and that'll take
you right down to the depths to find out
exactly why that's happening.
And it might be depths in her,
and it might be depths in newer,
it might be depths in both of you,
but,
and it's just
a bloody nightmare to get to the bottom
of that because first of all,
people will block you at every level.
You know,
the first thing they'll do is say,
I don't want to talk about it.
And then the next thing you'll do is
leave.
And then if you chase them,
they'll tell you that you're,
you know,
something associated with the scum of
the earth and you know,
cause you won't leave them alone.
Then they'll,
then they'll get angry and then they'll
burst into tears.
And then if you can still pursue it,
then you can have a conversation.
But no one,
hardly anyone ever gets to that point
because you just have to be brutal to,
to peck your way through those defenses.
The only way you're going to do it is if
you're more afraid of that stupid thing
continuing than you are of the terrible
conflict,
you're going to have to have to fix it.
And I don't think you can be that scared
unless you know what's at the bottom.
You think that is not good.
And you know,
if you know what not good means,
that new think,
hey,
we can have a fight for a couple of
days.
Man.
That's nothing compared to where this is
leading,
you know,
or where it to where it's from.
But people will rarely do that.
You'll see when you have your,
you establish your intimate
relationships,
you know,
this is a critical element of forging a
longterm union because there will be
things about you and your partner that
bug each other.
And those are places where your maps do
not coincide.
And sometimes that's for cultural and
familial differences.
But sometimes it's because one or both
of you is deviating seriously from the
proper script.
And those are hellacious fights,
you know?
And those are the sorts of things that
happen when someone gets really upset
about nothing.
You think that's not about nothing.
It's just,
it's like the nothing is is one hair on
a camel or something like that.
You know you don't have the damn camel
without the hair and even if it's one
hair,
you know there's a camel around so,
okay.
So anyways,
what bugs you?
Well that's that anomaly detector saying
something isn't right now you think
about the things that could be not
right.
It could be the external world,
it could be someone else and their value
structure and their behavior.
It could be your value structure and
behavior and when the thing that comes
up that bugs you hits,
you don't know which of those it is and
one of your tendencies and is going to
be to say it's the outside world or that
other person because the last place you
want to look as inside and that,
that's part of the reason that I find
increasingly find university campuses
intolerable because the default theory
when something isn't right is that it's
someone else's fault.
And I think that is pathological beyond
belief because the step from someone
else's fault too,
they should be punished for that is it's
trivial,
it's insignificant.
So you know,
the default position might be it's your
God damn fault.
Find where you went wrong and fix it.
And you might say,
well,
how can I be at fault?
It's like,
think about it for an hour.
You'll figure it out.
Like what?
Here's a very useful technique.
If you're fighting with someone that you
love,
you hit an impasse,
man.
You can't get anywhere.
You're misunderstanding each other,
you know,
and your tempers are flaring and you
know,
maybe it lasts for a week.
It's not entertaining.
You go sit on your bed and you think,
all right,
I probably did something stupid in the
last like three years that set me up for
this somehow.
And if you just allow yourself to
imagine your memory will take you to
some bloody idiotic thing that you did
that might seem to be only tenuously
related to the current circumstance,
but maybe it's the best you can offer.
Maybe you're only 5% at fault.
Well then you go tell the person while I
was thinking about this,
and it seems to me to that I set this up
like this,
and then they're all shorted out because
you know you've admitted fault and then
that may be allows them to admit fault.
They don't have to drive the spike home.
And then you can often have a dialogue,
but you don't get the dialogue until
you're willing to see yourself as a
contributor.
You know?
And the alternative,
and this is a terrible alternative,
is that you win the argument with your
partner.
Well,
good luck with that because all of that
will do is make the person who's better
at formulating the arguments,
the tyrant and the person who's worse,
the slave.
And then you got to decide,
well,
is this slave what you want as a
partner?
And maybe the answer's yes and no.
It could easily be because Japan,
oh,
could've just as easily picked the but
over the boy.
So,
so there's this,
so this,
the thing that bugs you,
you could think about that as a moral
responsibility.
And so maybe you go to work and
something bugs you and you think,
well,
I can just ignore that.
It's like,
don't be so sure your whole damn brain
is telling you there's a hole there,
there's a hole in the fabric of being
and something terrible is going to come
out of it unless you do something about
it.
And you can say,
well,
I'll ignore that.
But all that happens is the whole grows
and the monsters inside of it get bigger
and you get weaker.
And so eventually what happens is the
whole gets really big.
You get really small and something comes
out and eats you,
so you get fired or you get royally
screwed over at work or something like
that.
Or maybe someone sets up a conspiracy
where you're implicating something you
didn't even do and then you get fired
and you know it,
it doesn't have to end there.
And it's all because you didn't pay
attention to that thing that was bugging
you.
You know?
Maybe it was,
you were supposed to say to some
extraordinarily annoying coworker to
leave you the hell alone.
You know when it,
when it was still possible to say that
maybe even cause I politely,
so you know,
once you understand that your brain is
an early,
an early warning system and the things
that bug you are markers for holes
in Mba,
then it's a hell of a lot easier to
attend to them.
Now,
one more thing,
when I first watched this film,
or the first dozen times I watched it,
you know,
I was struck by the concordance between
Jimminy cricket and the figure of
Christ.
And it's weird because obviously
Pinocchio to some degree is that is the
infant save you,
right?
But then you have the cricket,
his initials are JC,
he serves as the conscience,
you know,
he's a moral guy.
So they're kind of inter twined in a
very weird way.
And when I was thinking about the
cricket as the Voice of value,
you know,
I thought it kind of thought about it as
an omniscient voice has a divine voice,
but that's not how the film portrays it.
What happens is it's so cool.
What happens is,
is that Pinocchio develops,
his conscience develops.
It's like there's a dialogue between
them.
So the conscious,
the conscious starts by just spouting
rules and you know,
your conscience does this to you all the
time.
If you watch what's going on in your
head,
you'll see that it continually
okay
assaults you with doubts and questions
about the validity of your Ba.
But if you,
if you notice,
and I dealt with this with people a lot,
a lot of the criticisms are sort of
generic.
You know,
it's like a chattering critic and you
can ignore a lot of it once you learn
how,
because you know like the criticism,
you're no good that's useless.
It's so low,
low resolution,
you just can't do anything with it.
What the film indicates,
and this is a very sophisticated ideas
that as you start making moral
judgments,
the first judgments your make your mate
are going to be low resolution and
generic.
They're going to be cliched.
But as you attempt to hone yourself and
maybe you start fixing the errors in
your,
in your mode of being,
then your ability to detect errors gets
better and better and finer and finer.
And so at some point you get to the
point where you're shipshape enough so
that you're going to detect little
deviations and jump on those suckers
right away.
And you won't even no one leave a notice
that you just fixed the problem.
And you know,
if you read any Dallas writings like the
Dao de chain,
once,
you know what I just told you,
read the Tao Te Ching,
it'll make perfect sense because the
Dow,
which is the pathway between chaos and
order,
the Dow is what you're supposed to
follow.
And the Dow is exactly what allows you
to avoid conflict without anybody even
notice it.
You know,
you just,
you see the thing pop out when there's
nothing to it,
you can just smooth it over maybe even
gently and no one even notices that you
did anything so
well.
So that's something to aim for.
You know,
that's definitely something game for it.
So,
and I,
I,
I've seen in my own life,
the best path to that is truth.
That's the best path.
And so,
you know,
part of what you might be thinking is
that as you're willing
to face the things that bug you,
sometimes when you intervene,
you're going to make a mistake.
You know,
you're not going to handle it.
Well,
maybe you'll even make the situation
worse.
But one of the consequences of that is
that you will learn something.
And so the more you learn,
you know,
the more you're informed and the more
you turn on your capacity to,
uh,
what would you say?
Creatively confront.
The sharper you get and the better you
get at it.
So you know,
it's going to be like this.
You know,
at the beginning you're,
you're going to be a pretty wobbly
system because what the hell do you know
about fixing things?
But if you practice it a thousand times
or 10,000 times or 100,000 times,
you know,
you'll get very good at it.
And that's exactly what this film
portrays is there's this dialog between
the generic conscience and you could
maybe think about that as the superego
or something akin to the 10 commandments
or something like that.
General principles of value.
There's a dialogue between the
individual and these general principles
of value so that the value principles
are updated and the individual gets
sharper and sharper.
And I can tell you a mythological
example of that.
So there's the scene in the New
Testament.
One of the things that happens quite
frequently in the New Testament,
and this is eventually why Christ gets
crucified,
is that he does moral things that are
forbidden.
So for example,
um,
there's a couple of episodes where it's
the Sabbath Day when you're not supposed
to do anything.
And someone comes into the synagogue or
the temple and their hand is all
withered up and he fixes their hand.
And then everybody was pretty freaked
out about that whole fixing thing.
But they also accused him of breaking a
divine rule.
And his answer to that is,
is the sabbath made for man or a man for
the Sabbath?
So,
and that's a very,
you got to understand that that's an
unbelievably revolutionary answer
because the prevailing morality,
and it's always the prevailing morality
was follow the damn rules.
And his action and response was not when
they don't serve the purpose for which
they were intended.
And so there's another explicit
statement of that in,
in the New Testament is very,
very interesting.
So
the,
by the time this story emerges in the
developmental story,
the Pharisees and the scribes.
So you could roughly think about that as
the priests and the lawyers,
that powerful,
powerful clique are already,
they already want to get rid of this guy
and they're trying to trap him into
saying something that's outright
heretical so they can lock them up or
kill them.
And so the lawyers are always coming
around them,
pestering him with complex ethical ideas
in the hope that it will trip up and
make a mistake.
And so one of the things they ask him
is,
which of the 10 commandments is the most
important?
And that's,
uh,
you know,
that's a hierarchy of principle.
Um,
question.
Well,
no matter what he says he's,
he's done.
Because if you say,
what is the most important,
you say the others are less important.
And so you can get hung out to dry on
your argument.
But that isn't what happens.
He says,
if I remember correctly,
uh,
love thy neighbor as thyself and then
says all of the commandments are
emanations of that single principle just
bypasses the question completely
brilliantly.
It's brilliant.
It's a paradigm shift in mood.
And of course that makes the people who
are pursuing him even more angry because
he made them into fools and showed them
how advanced his ability to debate was
over.
There's,
and then there's one other scene that
comes to mind where,
again,
I think it's in this,
in this situation where he's being
accused of undermining tradition and
they,
he's asked what his relationship is to
the tradition and he says,
I didn't come here to break the
traditional rules.
I came here as their fulfillment.
And so it's,
it's those sorts of things.
You see those in these mythological
stories and you think it's,
I do not buy for a second that that was
invented in any normative sense of the
word.
No statements are so sophisticated that
there that it's,
it's unbelievable.
They are so sophisticated now,
you know,
I see them emerging as a consequence of
a very lengthy development of
mythological imagination and knowledge.
But
Ah,
I just don't understand.
I cannot understand for a moment how
that could have possibly been thought
up.
So at least not by a single individual.
So you know,
when did the idea there too is that
passing through the narrow streets of a
rule system is one of the ways to
emerging on the other side of the rule
system.
So,
you know,
and that's all with regards to proper
relationships with the great father.
You know,
the other thing too is that if you allow
yourself to be passed through that
disciplinary process,
you also have firsthand experience of
its errors,
right?
Like if you want to fix the system,
unless you subject yourself to the
system,
how in the world are you ever going to
know what it did wrong?
You can't just stand from the outside as
an observer without having been passed
through it at every level and say,
well,
this is how it needs to be fixed.
It's like,
what the hell do you know about it?
There's no direct personal experience so
you don't necessarily even have a right
to comment.
So one of the things human suggested
should,
I think it's a boggling idea,
he thought you were always dreaming
awake or asleep,
but the dreams just went on continually
like maybe not 100% of the time,
but you were passing through dreams
continually.
And what was happening when you were
awake was that the,
the sensory pressure of the real world
was such that it just obliterate it.
Your knowledge of the dream.
And then when you went to sleep,
what happened was you shut off all your
sensory input roughly speaking and then
the sensitivity of your,
what do you say?
Signal to noise ratio changes so that
the background activity of your
underlying neural structures can start
to manifest itself and you can detect it
all that that might be the dream.
And I think there's a reference to that
here.
Whereas night progresses,
one of the things that happens to this
cricket is that it gets so sensitive to
anything,
you know,
it's getting more and more sensitive as
a detection device.
And so at some point it stops time
after all enough.
So that's pretty interesting because now
all of a sudden this bug is the master
of time.
He can bring time itself to a halt.
Okay,
now we're in a completely different
dimension.
We're in the real world,
so to speak.
Although it was obviously also with
dream,
like what's that movie where you go
through levels of dreaming.
Inception.
Yeah.
So you know the Pinocchio Stories are
all,
all obviously a dream.
And then we go down a level to a dream
within a dream.
And that's what we're in right now.
Watch out,
let's go.
Oh Hey.
So like what the hell do you know?
Really a star.
Dot Star comes down and turns into a
ferry.
It's like,
okay,
no one has any problem with that.
I mean the crickets a little freaked
out,
but everybody else seems to think that's
a perfectly reasonable low currents.
Which really begs the question,
how in the world can you understand that
you understand that?
Cause it's not understandable.
It makes no sense know,
like from a conscious or rational
perspective.
Okay,
so here's,
here's what's happening.
We notice that there's a real absence of
femininity so far in,
uh,
in the story.
It's sort of implicit in the comfort of
the home,
but there's nothing explicit it now
you can think of Japan as the beneficial
element of culture.
And so here's the way of conceptualizing
it.
If the beneficial aspect of culture is
put into place,
the beneficial elements of nature is
called forth.
And so,
you know,
I can give you an example.
Like if you have a neurologically
damaged infant and that infant grows up
in a chaotic environment,
the probability that that neurological
damage will result in severe behavioral
and social impairments is quite high.
But if you take an individual like that
and you raise them in a stable
environment,
then they can often stabilize their
nervous systems.
And so you can see that there's a dance
between nature and culture as a child
develops and that,
you know,
if you set the culture up properly,
then the child's nature has the capacity
to manifest itself in the most
beneficial manner possible.
Now it would be partly the facilitation
of individual development.
You know,
because the child is a variant of a
human being and you want to apply or
cultural structure to it,
to the child so that it becomes
socialized and,
and disciplined and able to do things.
But at the same time you want it to
manifest its particularities.
So you've got to get the balance right.
Well Japan or made the wish,
it's the right wish.
So nature comes to the rescue and in its
most benevolent forum and it's
attractive and seductive.
This is almost like,
you know,
Buddhist farther setting up all the
dancing girls in the forest because
this,
this figure is part of what entices
people into life,
but certainly entices babies into life.
You know,
the love that a mother provides is a
seduction into life.
And no wonder because
you need to be seduced into living.
It's too hard otherwise,
you know,
and if babies don't have that primary
relationship with their mother,
they just fold up and die,
fed,
warm,
bathed,
irrelevant.
They have to have that relationship.
Great.
So right away,
you know,
there's a,
there's a hint to give them so much
happiness to others.
There's a hint of the sexual element
there.
And so this particular ferry was modeled
on a screen queen of the time,
you know,
a woman who was famous for her beauty.
And you know,
there's,
there's a knob here to something which
is that there are multiple elements of
being that have nothing to do with
rationality that are necessary,
that are necessary components of the
nature that entices you into life.
You know,
and one of those primary sources of
energy obviously,
and delight and motivation and all of
those things,
his sexuality and his Freud pointed out,
it permeates all levels of human
endeavor.
And you know,
we have some trouble with that because
it's,
you know,
sexuality is such a powerful force that
wherever you introduce,
it's like a divine force.
It produces rifts in the cultural
structure.
You know,
hand sold a continual debate about
sexual harassment and so forth in the
workplace.
You know,
you have men and women in the same
places all the time.
And so there's the normative day
to day cultural things that are supposed
to be occurring,
narrow in goal directed and the
consistent,
you know,
eruption of sexuality into that well and
you could say,
well that should just be stopped.
It's like be careful what you say.
Do you really want to stop it while you
think,
yeah,
it gets out of hand and rudy fast.
It's like,
yeah it does.
But two attempts to suppress it.
So you know you're stuck with it.
It's,
it's an unalterable element of life's
complexity and it's also something that
pulls you forward into life.
So you can imagine the level of tyranny
that would be necessary to eradicate all
sexual interactions from the workplace.
You just,
everyone would wear a uniform.
Everyone would have their haircut
exactly the same.
No one would ever wear makeup.
You know,
you,
you have to be rendered as neutral as
possible and even not wouldn't do it.
But that would be the start of doing it.
Come through
little puppet made a pie.
See Young would regard that little blue
fairy as an anima finger.
An animal.
Anima means soul.
And so there's an idea here that you
know,
the masculine great fathers sort of
constructed the structure that's an oak
hill.
So that would be the nuts and bolts of
the individual as a cultural construct.
And then the sort of divine and enticing
feminine spirit breathes life into it.
And so,
you know,
there are situations where that causal
sequence could be reversed depending on
what was being exemplified or amplify.
But that's what's happening here.
So he wakes up and he becomes self
conscious per pretty much immediately.
I've given you a nice host tonight.
You her wished for real,
no Cahokia to make two pillows wish come
true.
It would be entirely up to you,
prove yourself truthful and unselfish
and someday you will be over your gone.
Okay?
So there's a variety of extraordinarily
complex things going on here.
So you know,
one of the things that you'll hear
constantly bandied about in a quasi
scientific community is the role of
nature and nurture.
Okay?
So we could say architecturally for,
for our purposes at the moment in this
film,
nurture is being represented by Japan
because he's constructing things in
nature by the ferry.
So you can say,
well,
nature nurture the role of biology
versus culture.
Well,
it's a,
it's an interesting ediology we'll say
because it makes a proposition and the
proposition is that's the only two
causal elements that are operating,
right?
Nature,
culture,
mother,
father,
let's say roughly speaking.
Then you ask yourself,
well,
where the hell's the individual in this
equation?
And the answer is nowhere at all because
there's no causal role for the
individual in a scientific psychology.
It's either nature or nurture.
Now that the film,
weirdly enough,
has a theory that's I would say is more
sophisticated than that.
It says nature's necessary culture is
necessary and it would be best if they
were optimized.
So you get a head start,
for example,
if your father actually loves you and so
does your mother fair enough?
But that isn't sufficient in and of
itself to produce,
you know,
an individual who inhabits the
transcendent zone.
There's actually choices that have to be
made.
Now,
I would say our entire culture is
predicated on the idea that people
actually make choices.
You know,
our,
our culture is predicated on the idea of
individual responsibility and choice.
So we recognize that in our legal system
and we recognize it in our individual
interactions because you always treat
people around you as if they could have
chosen something different.
You know,
unless they can make a really strong
case that they couldn't.
And then you say,
oh,
well,
you know,
then you're not responsible for it.
No,
I was in a court case at one point and
the person who was on trial had been
forced to help kill someone with the
rock after she'd been stripped naked and
threatened with death and rape.
And it was a credible threat because
she'd already watched the people that
were threatening her,
beat someone 95% to death.
And so she dropped a rock on the guide
and you know,
then there's a rule in,
in law,
you're not,
no matter what duress you're subject to,
you don't get to do that.
But this was such an ex she got there
accidentally.
She just blundered into the situation.
She was a single mother and also very
worried that you know,
if she got killed,
you know who the hell was going to take
care of her kid and well and so forth.
But you know the,
the court eventually found in her favor.
And the reason for that was that the
court,
that was the first time in English
common law history that that had ever
happened.
But the court decided that under those
circumstances she wasn't acting as an,
she had no will,
like the circumstance was so compelling
that she did what you would expect
someone to do.
Because the law is also by the way,
optimized for the average individual,
not for the hero.
The law does not demand of you that you
act like a hero.
And thank God for that.
So I know.
So if someone says,
look,
I couldn't help it,
and then you believe that you don't
judge them,
but if they can't make that case,
your automatic presupposition is you
could have done something differently.
And you might ask yourself,
you know,
to the degree that you're an admirer of
nature versus nurture,
you know,
culture versus nature or biology versus
culture.
Why in the world do you believe that
people have any,
any avenue of choice,
but you do you act that out in your
beliefs all the time.
Um,
or like more human options,
like the results.
It doesn't just like,
I feel like there's no,
well,
you know,
the problem with that viewpoint is it's
fundamentally deterministic.
Yeah.
But,
but the reality isn't deterministic.
It's probabilistic.
And so you can't,
like the,
one of the things that quantum mechanics
makes quite evident is that you cannot
draw on airinc cause and effect chains.
Okay.
Yeah.
But I know,
I know it is.
I know it is,
but we also exist at the microscale and
I'm also not saying that what the movie
is putting forth is true.
I'm just telling you what it's putting
forth.
The movements,
it's still
worse.
We'll,
well this seems non random to me.
Okay.
Well yeah.
You know,
we know what I mean.
That's,
but that's more like,
because I haven't started this
conversation,
you wouldn't have done that sort of,
again,
it's a result of link.
Lord,
you know,
I,
I'm,
I'm not making a case for the,
I'm not making a case for the ultimate
validity of this viewpoint.
Okay.
Or at least if I am,
I'm not expecting you to believe it.
What I'm saying is that there's a
tension between this viewpoint,
which is an archetypal and mythological
viewpoint and the scientific viewpoint.
And you know,
the way that a person would object to
this viewpoint is by saying,
hold on a minute.
There's deterministic causality at work.
You know,
I would say in favor of this perspective
is we don't act that way.
And you know,
maybe we're wrong,
but we do not act that way.
We shouldn't.
Why not?
Well,
because,
because it's an attractive,
because I like it wouldn't work,
but then I wouldn't object if it,
if it wouldn't work.
That actually indicates that it's wrong.
And that goes back to this sort of
debate between Darwin and Newton.
Yeah.
This is wrong.
Not objectively wrong in the sense that
it gets not a good way to
sure you can say it's wrong.
Pragmatically you couldn't say that.
And that could be the case.
You could make a case that we act as if
we have free will because that's the
simplest solution to the problem.
Yeah,
you could.
And you know it's a perfectly reasonable
argument.
Just say that,
I don't believe it but,
but it's,
but as,
as a coherent argument,
it's,
it's fine.
It's partly why there is such tension
between scientific and mythological
views of the world.
This is a huge part of the tension.
You know,
part of it is evolution versus
creationism.
It's like who cares about that?
That's a stupid argument.
But this one is much more difficult,
you know,
that's determinism versus choice.
That's part of it.
And there's much to be said on both
sides.
And of course are deterministic models
of the world are extraordinarily
powerful and we use them all the time.
So we also act out our belief in those
models.
So,
okay,
so back to Pinocchio.
So now he's got his own voice.
So that means,
you know,
partly what that means is that by the
time you launch your child into the
world,
they should have their own voice.
You actually see that developing in
kids.
You see that really developing when
they're about to because that's when
they learn to say no and like 50% of
what a two year old will say to you is,
no,
I used to fool my son cause he would say
no to everything.
He'd say no to things like 10 things in
a row.
And then I'd ask him if he wanted some
chocolate ice cream.
Then the first thing he would say is no.
And then he,
you know,
startle a bit and think,
wait,
I actually do want some chocolate ice
cream.
So but,
but we know people called the terrible
twos,
the terrible twos because that is when
the child discovers it's voice,
it learns how to push back and then so
it's dependent,
then it's oppositional,
then it starts to become cooperative.
You know when you want the child to be a
nice balance between opposition land
cooperative roughly by the time they hit
three and for sure by the time they hit
four,
because if they don't do it by the time
they hit four,
it's like the crucial developmental
period in many ways his past.
So,
or you're too stupid to learn how to
interact with your kid and you know
what,
it basically boils down to the same
thing.
So now he has his voice and he has some
limited autonomy.
And the first thing that blue fairy
tells him is that he has a moral
adventure in front of him and that it's
going to involve following some rules
and they're pretty prosaic and
stereotypical rules.
You know,
they're like a lecture from your,
maybe not so favorite act or something
like that.
Easy.
You was hard to choose between right and
wrong.
But how do I know how I know your
conscience with your
options?
Just that still small voice but people
won't question.
So He's kind of a loud mouth at this
point and he holds himself up a little
podium to,
to,
you know,
speech or fight from.
And one of the things you'll see us,
his voice is quite patronizing and phony
and it's also very hard to listen to
him.
Like the next five things he says,
they have no life in them.
They're boring.
And that's because they're basically
debt rules.
They're necessary,
but they've got no spirit in them.
And he's also got this pointing thing
going on,
you know,
so he's like a hectoring,
superego type of creature and he's too
dumb to stay out of the situation.
Right.
He leaps into it,
you know,
without even thinking really.
And so it's a good commentary on your
conscience because that damn thing can
drive you crazy.
And the thing is,
even though it's necessary and partly
right,
it's also destructive and not completely
right.
So,
you know,
that makes it very difficult to know how
to relate to it.
Just the problem with the world today.
Oh hello.
Would you like to be conscious
about?
How does your name Oh credits you have
any quick neil,
Mr
you can.
Oh,
countries not high.
Keep her
counselor
and guide it on the street and down.
So jimminy cricket,
but don't we get a badge or something?
We'll see.
Well,
I shouldn't.
Okay.
So again,
a variety of very complex things happens
there.
Um,
first of all,
but conscience undergoes a
transformation at the same time as the
boy does.
And so I think the way of thinking about
that is that it's something like,
you know,
obviously human beings are predisposed
to learn language,
whatever that means.
One of the things that infants do when
they're in their crib,
you'll hear them badly and they're
playing with,
they're playing with sounds,
and I don't know if you know this,
but an infant babbles every human phony.
So there's four different phonemes
speech elements in different languages.
You know what one interesting,
different saves between many Asian
languages in English.
There's no distinction between the r
sound or end.
The old found in many Asian languages
and so often Asian people can't even
hear that difference.
And they certainly can't say it and
there's,
there's lots of sounds,
but that English speakers have a hard
time with many,
many sounds in Asian languages,
lots of sounds in German.
Um,
you know,
there was throat,
throat sounds that are kind of guttural.
And then there's click languages and you
know,
there's all sorts of things that not
only can you,
not by the time you're an adult and
trained in one language,
but you can't even hear them.
Now the child is sitting there battling
in every single phony,
which is amazing.
It's as if it knows the units of every
possible language.
And then what happens is it loses the
ability to admit phonemes that are of
that language.
It's so not what you'd expect,
man.
You'd expect that it doesn't know a damn
thing.
And then it learns the particular full
names,
not that it knows every phoneme and then
loses the ability.
That's very peculiar.
Okay.
So you could say in some sense that the
child has a low resolution,
broad adaptations to possible languages
now.
And I would say,
well the same thing comes with regards
to conscious is the child has the
inbuilt mechanism for conscience.
You know,
and it could be developed in a very
large number of specific ways.
You know,
they,
they fit within a universe of potential,
what would you call playable moral
games.
So it's not unbounded,
it's not infinite but,
but,
but it's,
it's large.
And then so the child comes equipped
with that.
And then what happens is that it's an,
as it's inculturated,
the conscience starts to pick up the
specific rules that underlie that
cultures,
motive,
social interaction and that sort of the
generic corn chance.
And so that's what it is at this point.
You know,
it's been well developed.
That's why it's got this sort of rich
nature.
It's not fully developed,
ignores that itself.
That's why it's still wants the damn
gold badge.
It's a lot better than it was when it
was just a tramp that had been
everywhere.
Right.
Cause now it's specifically allied with
an individual.
And so that's interesting too because
the movie posits that the conscience
requires the individual to develop just
as the individual requires.
The conscience to develop.
It's very cool,
very sophisticated idea.
And so now they're both sent out
fundamentally to learn.
Now the conscience is a little wiser
because in some sense it's been
everywhere.
Right?
Well that was partly why it was a tramp
to begin with.
But it also,
the interesting thing too is that it
doesn't have full control over the
individual.
You know,
and that's a strange thing too because
it's not,
it's also not what you would expect from
a purely deterministic system.
You know,
a deterministic system you think would
be bound by the rules.
Well,
maybe we are in a very complex way,
but certainly not in any simple way.
That's rule two,
two behavior.
You know the rules,
but you don't have to follow them.
We all
always let your conscience,
oh yeah,
I almost forgot about you.
Well,
hello.
Maybe you and I better have a little to
heart talk.
Want to be a real boy.
I don't,
you
know,
you see the world is full of him page.
Yeah,
they're in the wrong things,
but seek right at the time.
But,
um,
even though the right things may seem
wrong sometimes and sometimes the wrong
things,
but maybe right at the wrong time or
vice advisor
had a boy and I'm going to help.
So there's a nice little philosophical
conundrum there.
It's quite sophisticated.
It's even the conscience can say state
explicitly the rules of the game,
right?
So,
so much of it is implicit now he's kind
of narcissistic at this point and thinks
he knows a lot more than he does know.
When he tries to articulate the rules,
he finds that he doesn't know them.
And even if he did,
the thing to which they're being
articulated cannot follow matt an
articulated level.
So,
you know,
and what that really means is people do
this with your two year olds all the
time.
They explain the rules to them.
It's like,
it's virtually pointless because a two
year old,
they don't,
they aren't governed by rules.
Adults aren't governed by rules.
Why in the world would you ever expect
that the two year old to be guided by
rules and they certainly can't
articulate them.
You know?
Now,
if you're careful,
there's certain things that you can
articulate for a two year old,
but explaining complex moral concepts to
them is that's just not how they learn
how to behave.
They learn how to behave by bugging you,
roughly speaking and seeing what
happens.
But not only that,
they come for comfort and they laugh
like they're,
they're charting the interactions
constantly and extracting all rules.
They're learning it through experience.
And that's basically what happens here
at the,
the,
the conclusion for the conscience and
the puppet as well.
We have to learn through experience.
It's something that has to be acted out,
not explained in an articulated way.
Okay.
Just like,
all right,
we'll skip the little song.
Okay.
So now it's the next morning.
Wow.
So,
you know,
you can see by his behavior that he's
being raised well because he's very
enthusiastic.
Hence the hopping around,
you know,
and he's not powering,
you could also say,
well,
he's got the temperament for it and
fine.
He's not cowering,
you know,
afraid of the world and Japan,
Oh,
isn't going to walk him to school,
you know,
old Japan.
Oh,
is courageous enough we could say and
know,
but also confident enough in Pinocchio's
capacity at this point to say,
okay,
you know you're going to manage it.
And it's not like he's naive and figures
that there's no,
that there's no danger.
That's not,
that's not it at all.
It's that he feels that the child is
developed enough so that the next
logical step is to allow him some
freedom of choice in the actual world.
So that's what he proceeds to do.
Now there's sign that he's a good
father.
He's not,
Pinocchio isn't cotton.
They need a whole family that won't let
him go.
It's encouraging him to move out into
the world.
One
teacher,
ow.
Oh yeah.
He doesn't forget to give them a book.
Come
back.
Listen
[inaudible] school,
I'm no institution would be stupid.
Well,
well Stromboli so the battle arrest,
so this farkes is well,
cynical and shallow at the same time and
all he ever does is lie.
So every single word is a lie.
And you can tell that in the falsity of
his voice.
And so I was back in it.
I could give you the time.
I tied sleeves on you.
We nearly put one over on that old
gypsy.
That time
you might not want to be with a fortune
to someone.
Let me see.
That's it.
Okay.
So because of long practice,
these two are more adept deadline line
and Pinocchio is at detecting false
hood.
Okay.
So he,
he's,
he's still naive and that's not the same
as good.
He's not doing,
he's not evil.
He's neither.
He's just naive and people often
mistake.
Now evd for good.
I couldn't imagine doing that.
That doesn't make you good at,
just makes you naive.
And so it's definitely one of the,
you know,
direct threats in the world when the
puppet goes out.
He actually doesn't encounter like an
Avatar of tire map.
It's not a natural force.
It's not a crocodile.
It's not danger lurking somewhere
that's,
you know,
off the natural world.
It's the corrupt social world.
So you could think about this as his
encounter with seth.
Although these guys are like low rent
versions of Seth,
you know,
they're,
they're petty evil.
Speak on the
cons,
right?
You Sleep,
oh my name is molly's job.
How's that?
No one else,
any cops.
Oh,
oh,
I'm sorry.
So he's off to school.
He's gone.
His book soul,
you know,
he's,
he's heading straight towards the,
the conventional path to knowledge and
enculturation safe and something trips
them up.
Well we know how that works.
And so what trips you up is chaos.
And then,
you know,
chaos can manifest itself as many
forums.
And what it manifests itself here as is,
is like low level of malevolence.
So they've got plans for him that he
knows nothing about and all the plans
are,
is exploited.
And so you could think about that as one
of the canonical existential problems
that people face in the world.
And what happens is Pinocchio faces a
number of canonical existential
challenges and they're not trivial.
Obviously.
He's no match for these characters even
though they're like,
you know,
they're pretty rich.
It as far as thugs go.
No,
I see
a man of letters,
that
personality,
this party is more relevant now than it
was when it was first,
when it was first produced.
I mean,
you know,
people were obsessed with fame at this
point,
but it has nothing like it is today
where we have people who are famous
merely for being famous.
And you know,
part of the reason that they're famous
is because they're there.
They're like anti stars indicate in a
sense what they indicate to people,
and this is partly why they're popular,
is that you can get to the top of the
hierarchy of power and influence without
having anything that distinguishes you
whatsoever except maybe some random
attractive feature.
You know?
And that's,
that's precisely what's being talked
about here.
And so it took me a long time to figure
out why in the world was this film so
critical of actors?
I thought it was produced by Hollywood.
It's like they're engaged in this
dramatic game.
So what's wrong with actor,
but it's not actor in the actor Sam's,
it's persona in the psychological sense.
Do you want to be the real thing or you
want to be something who appears to be
the real thing?
It's a lot easier.
And that way you could,
you can attain all the advantages of
status and power without having to have
done anything that actually contributes
to the system in which that kind of
status and power is actually possible.
So basically what you're doing is you're
Europe,
simulacrum of of competence.
And you know the fox here like that
already.
He's cynical about school,
but when he holds a book,
he holds it upside down.
He has no idea what he's being cynical
about.
And so you might think of this as the
first,
it's what?
It's not necessarily bow first
temptation,
but it's at first temptation.
It's the temptation of persona.
Are you going to be really who you are
or you're going to be an actor?
Well,
Pinocchio obviously picks actor and no
wonder,
you know,
it's,
it's a convincing possibility and that
would be associated with youngs idea of
development of the persona.
But the persona is also a necessary
thing to develop.
So you could also think about this as a
developmental phase.
You need to learn how to act in public.
And so if you learn to well how to act
in public,
well then there's nothing left of you
and it's a catastrophe.
But if you don't learn at all,
well that's equally it.
Catastrophe.
So,
okay.
So anyways,
he's suckered in by these guys.
I can see your name in lights,
lights,
six feet high.
Name
no po P.
Dot.
William wasting precious come
home.
Yes.
Horrible thing.
Okay.
So the conscience basically tells him
it's very interesting.
You see this little look where he is.
No,
that thing in the background there.
Well I don't know if I can eat
and explain it.
I'll try to explain it.
One of the holiest Hindus symbols is,
is the Yoni Lingham.
Um,
combination,
masculine and feminine.
It's like a container and a phallic
cylinder and it's often in gold and it's
often the thing that's at the center of
a temple and it's a car.
It's a symbol for the original
juxtaposition of masculine and feminine.
The creative juxtaposition of masculine
and feminine.
Okay.
So it's also a symbol,
it's like a taoist symbol.
It's also very similar to the Jewish
star,
which is a female triangle.
And a male triangle put together.
And so it's a combination.
It's,
it's a symbol of the unity out of which
valuable things spring Hanse it'd be
gold.
Well the cricket is speaking from that.
And so you could also say that the
conscience in some sense is the voice
of,
it's the voice of the combination of
masculine and feminine from him from a
mythological perspective.
And it's trying to speak natural wisdom
or,
or maybe it's trying to speak wisdom.
That's the optimal combination of
natural and cultural wisdom and trying
to convince Pinocchio that this isn't a
good idea,
but he doesn't listen.
So then he gets,
he meets this Italian,
a scam artist fundamentally who in
slaves him well pretending that he's
doing a good thing and you could see
them.
The cricket is
not very happy about this.
Where is that?
Okay.
Right there.
He's Very
Unhappy About Pinocchio.
Was d two or into cheap attention
getting okay.
Yeah.
So you see there the emergence of the
tyrannosaur farther,
like you know,
in that explosion of Rage is Pinocchio
was not acting his puppet part.
And so there's instant rage on the part
of the tyrant now when he finds out that
the crowd is happy about his now a slave
making,
a fool of himself,
that that's also funny and that that can
garner attention,
that it's all,
it's all,
you know,
put away.
So,
and you know,
it's certainly possible for children to
be caused by celebrities by acting
badly.
Like if you've been around badly behaved
children,
especially if they're kind of
professional added,
that's exactly what they do there.
You know,
they absorb all the attention in the
room and they do that by acting in a
suboptimal way.
And it's a terrible thing to see happen.
And that's exactly what's being played
out here.
You know,
their parents think they're giving them
freedom,
but they're not there.
They're quite the contrary.
Okay.
So anyways,
so Pinocchio does his Little Act
and shows that he's capable of
autonomous action.
He makes a fool of himself again at the
end and
Oh shit.
Okay.
And then this scene,
Japan goes out to look for Pinocchio
because he hasn't come home.
All right?
And so then now we're back after the
performance.
Boom.
Sure.
I would push you in the public's eyes,
your face.
She would be on everybody's down.
Yeah.
Uh Huh.
Uh,
you,
my,
you go to her no heel.
Yeah.
God,
you're going to go home at the old
mother
Mary called beat.
Well,
you obviously know what's going to
happen next.
So he's now become a prisoner of this
thing that's exploiting
him and it threatens him.
And then of course he's kidnapped.
So the cricket goes off to look for,
what was that show?
Don't you worry,
I'll have you out of here in no time at
all.
Why?
This is just as easy
[inaudible]
animosity.
Okay.
So neither the conscience nor Pinocchio
can make it out of here.
And so they're both trapped because this
is actually a very sneaky,
difficult position to be it all right.
But
anyway,
I tell her the truth.
You know,
there's an idea about creative people
that they have a muse and the muse is
often a feminine figure.
And there's a variety of reasons for
that.
But some of the were played out in this
movie.
But the idea to some degree is,
is that,
you know,
if you're out in no man's land in chaos,
maybe you've broken a social rule that
there's the possibility that you can
garner something positive from it if
your attitude is proper.
And that's part of what's happening here
is that he encounters the positive
element of deviation deviating from the
path.
But there's also something a little more
subtle,
which is the idea that
your nature is robust enough to tolerate
a certain amount of deviation from the
proper course.
You can tolerate like oscillations back
and forth into too much order.
It too much chaos without it completely
undermining you.
But then the movie also makes a point is
that that works best if you're not
falsifying your own experience.
And of course this is the part of the
movie that,
that Everybody Who Watches Pinocchio
always remembers is that when he tells a
lie,
his nose growth,
right?
Making him making the lie obvious to
others fundamentally.
And you know,
the,
the simple moral from the stories don't
lie.
And of course that's,
that's a primary part of the
developmental sequence in the movie.
Part of the problem with the lie is that
it prevents you from repairing your own
structure because you deny the existence
of the error.
And what do you do then is accumulate
errors as you move through time.
And if you do that long enough then all
you are is there and then you're really
in
trouble because part of your conscience
is speaking from the error ridden
domain.
And so the more you pathologize your own
internal structure or say your
relationship with the broader community,
the less it is possible for you to
realize it.
To rely on that in build voice of
conscience because it gets pathologized
too.
And so you can imagine that as the
development of a positive feedback loop.
The more you tell yourself lies,
the more ben your perceptions become.
And and the more unstable the self
guiding mechanism so to speak inside of
you becomes.
So that's the corruption of the self is.
And then the corruption of the state.
You know,
one of the things you hypothesize
where's the people are almost always
bugged by,
by things that are also partly that are
connected in some important way.
To the social community.
And one of the things he suggested was
that if you really fix your own
problems,
you know the problems that have
announced themselves to you within your
own personal space,
if you took them on is your problems to
fix.
You would also be simultaneously
retooling the social structure in so far
as you were able to do that.
Because there's no,
there's no only fixing you,
you know,
you,
you change the social structure around
you just by fixing yourself.
And so what that also means is that to
the degree that you failed to respond to
your own knowledge of error,
and this is what makes it so cool.
It isn't,
this process is isn't someone else
telling you that you're wrong,
it's you telling yourself that you're
wrong.
And so it doesn't,
failure to abide by the rules because
the rules,
while the conscience is the arbiter of
they're unstable,
necessary but unstable.
But you're,
you're,
the moral battle that you're obliged to
pass through is it is a product of your
own construction.
And so it's as if you're playing a game
and then where you make up the rules and
then cheating,
not useful.
Cool.
Oh,
it's writing it.
Anyway.
So now he's given up
back to nature.
I tell her the truth.
Ah,
oh
wow.
This
Nokia,
why didn't you go to school?
Go ahead Tom.
Yeah.
The other thing that's happening here
obviously is that he,
as he lies,
he becomes less human and more would
like.
So
hence the,
you know,
the nose growing.
So anyways,
he learns that that's a bad idea and the
ferry gives them a hand and he escapes
out of that.
Hypothetically having learned something.
Okay,
now I want you to follow this.
So you remember at the beginning of the
movie,
Pinocchio,
God,
his smile,
you saw that negative male figure
glaring out of it.
And then we saw the same negative fee
figure male figure in the,
uh,
you know,
in the Gypsy who the kidnapping gypsy.
Now they're harsh,
tyrannical male.
Okay.
So what you're doing is,
and then of course there's the Fox and
the cat.
You're seeing different incarnations are
avatars of the,
of the negative.
Great fodder.
And you know,
with,
I would say some contamination by the
adversary,
but we'll,
we'll just stick with the negative.
Great farther.
Right now,
what happens here is the actual
archetype reveals itself.
So you could think of this as a,
you know,
it's a daunting is inferno model.
Pinocchio is coming into contact with
things that are more and more serious.
And what you see here is the petty petty
evil guys bragging about how remarkable
they are to the coachman coachman's that
typical archetipal a representation of
Satan.
So the coachman is someone who takes you
where you don't want to go.
You know,
it's something that,
that it's,
it's your,
your placement within the confines of an
autonomous force.
So what you see here is they encounter
the coachman and the coachman doesn't
reveal who he is except in one place.
And what's interesting,
so it's all of a sudden he transforms
from a,
a mere character in the movie.
So to speak,
to the archetype itself.
It reveals itself.
And then the gates slam back shop.
And one of the things that's very
interesting is that that revelation is
sufficient even to terrify the thugs
because in some sense they have no idea
what they're messing with.
You know,
and they're very art.
They're very narcissistic and
egotistical and they think that they're
going to get away with what they're
doing forever and you know that they're
really not so bad anyways.
And that the people they're praying on
it deserve it because they're stupid and
you know,
they're full of rationalizations,
but they get a glimpse of what it is
that's animating them and it terrifies
them.
This job's too
coach man.
What's your brother's name?
How would you like to make some money?
And who do we ask to it?
Nothing.
You see,
you'll know the disability.
No,
no,
no
crossing.
You always meet the Devil at the
crossroads,
right?
Cause every blues singer notes.
Why?
Because the crossroads is a binary
choice.
Right.
And there's the right road in the wrong
road.
So the devil always be two at the
crossroads.
So,
and that's where the coachman meets the
boys.
It's a decision point.
So,
okay.
So something up is something is up that
isn't good.
So Pinocchio is going back to school and
then he gets stopped again.
Okay,
the snake
to
go,
no sir,
nothing can stop me now I will.
I'm going to school.
That's it.
Victim.
That's the next temptation.
So,
and the victim Motif is a deep one.
So basically what the Fox tells the boy
now is that there's a bunch of things
wrong with it.
Well obviously right?
Because there's a bunch of things wrong
with everyone,
but,
and so he can make a perfectly
reasonable claim of that.
And then he convinces the boy that the
fact that there's something wrong with
him justifies his deviation from what
he's supposed to do.
And that's,
that's a classical eatable trick,
by the way,
if you want to keep your kids at home
and make sure that they never leave and
render them completely useless,
what you want to do is watch them toy
with their own vulnerability and then
encourage that,
you know?
So if the kid,
you ever use this being ill as a,
an excuse,
which every kid will absolutely do,
especially if they have to go do
something they don't want to do,
like go to school,
you just give in every time they do
that.
Or if you really want to do a good job,
what you do is you reward them every
time they do that and you punish them
every time they do the opposite.
And if you do that 150,000 times,
then you'll have someone who will be
absolutely incapable of standing on
their own two feet.
And that's very helpful for you.
If that's the sort of person you want to
have around that,
usually you're usually inclined to do
that if you don't have a life of your
own,
you know,
and you can't even tolerate the
possibility of ever being alone.
So you cripple your child so they can't
leave.
Yeah.
So that's essentially what's being
offered to Pinocchio now.
And then the,
the Fox says,
look,
you're way too stressed.
Everything's too terrible.
What you need is a vacation.
So what we're going to do is replace
the,
the duty,
so to speak to them.
You know,
the movement forward towards the proper
goal with nothing but fun and games.
So it's,
you could say it's a future discounting
in the extreme,
forget about the future.
Life is hard.
Concentrate on the present,
do the easy fun things and you deserve
it anyways because you're in such rough
shape,
you can see that that's a very
compelling temptation.
I mean,
I had a child who is quite ill for a
long time and one of the things we
really struggled with was if you have,
you're with someone who's really ill,
how the hell do you know when to excuse
them from their obligations?
You know,
like I could never,
we had to,
we had the negotiate this all the time.
So my,
my,
my one child was very,
very tired in the morning,
terribly tired.
It was a secondary consequence of this
particular illness.
But you know,
we were trying to negotiate that.
It's like you have to go what you have
to do,
unless you absolutely can't.
Okay.
When can't you?
Well,
God,
can you do it if you can crawl out the
door?
I don't know.
Did you ever see my left foot?
It's an amazing movie.
It's based on a true story.
It's about this kid who,
I think he had cerebral palsy but he
couldn't really do anything with his
body except with his left foot.
He could drag himself around with his
left foot and he learned to write and he
learned to draw and he learned how to
communicate.
And you went to school.
But as far to just wouldn't help him.
He dragged himself up and down the
stairs.
Like he had to do everything with his
left foot.
And you know,
he managed,
he managed to live that way.
But you know,
I just,
I can't,
I don't think I've ever met anyone in
the modern world who would be tough
enough to do what his father did because
you know,
you'd say,
well,
have some compassion.
It's like,
yeah,
well compassion is a double edge sword,
you know,
and the basic rule,
I can tell you what the rule is,
and this is a rule that's often used in
nursing homes.
Never do anything for anyone they can do
themselves.
And you think,
well that's,
that's harsh man part because you have
to find out what they can do.
But it's also respect for their autonomy
and encouragement to continue developing
so
well.
So that isn't what happens here.
You know,
one of the things I told my child was
never use your illness as an excuse.
Not even once.
Because as soon as you do that,
even once,
you won't be able to tell the difference
between being sick and wanting to be
sick.
And when you're sick like that and you
know,
50 things is wrong with you,
it's already hard enough to figure out
what you can do and what you can't do,
man,
you drop a little bit of poison into
that brew and like it's just toxic mess
everywhere.
We must diagnosis cases once we got the,
Yup.
So basically what happens here is that
by over attending to Pinocchio's,
let's say neurotic doubts,
the parent figure produces,
uh,
like hop,
hop,
hypochondriasis,
you know,
because partly what parents kids are
doing is saying,
I feel like this,
what does that mean?
My throat hurts a bit.
Does that mean I don't have to go to
school?
Well,
for sure you don't have to go to school
and there's probably eight other things
wrong with you.
You know,
and then let's spend a bunch of time
looking for them.
Maybe we can have a hug and a cuddle
while we're doing that.
And I don't have to watch my stupid soap
operas and you could stay home from
school and keep me company.
It's a little conspiracy,
you know?
So the child learns to do that and to
bloody will exploit that like mad.
And the parent can justify doing that
with the feeling that they're being
compassionate.
So it's a nasty,
nasty little game.
And that's partly why it's laid out
here.
So anyways,
he convinced his Pinocchio,
the sick,
making him sick in the process and then
telling him he needs a vacation.
So off they go.
Vacation time.
Yeah.
Okay.
So this nasty little character we're
going to beat now,
meet now.
His name is lamp wake.
And I think that's a reference to
Lucifer.
It's the same category of word and he's
a prematurely cynical,
delinquent type of kid and he's got a
very superior and arrogant attitude
cause he goes everything cause nothing's
worth knowing.
And he's the adversary.
He's Pinocchio's shadow.
That's,
that's one way of thinking about
written.
So Pinocchio meets a Chateau,
which of course every teenager meets
when they're a teenager because that's
who you meet when you're a teenager,
right?
It's,
it's that part of the developing ego
that's challenging the structure of the
community and often doing that by
breaking rules.
And so that's what people always talk
about as pure pressure.
You know,
are you going to try this bad thing or
are you going to try that bad thing?
You know,
kids have to experiment with that.
And so it's part of the deal.
It's part of the developmental
progression.
And you know,
the question is well,
why not behave badly and break all the
rules and be on disciplined and you
know,
take every advantage it's at your
fingertips.
That's a perfectly reasonable question.
Let me say it's a swell job.
No school,
no.
Nobody says,
oh boy.
Oh
boy.
That's the place.
The other thing that's interesting about
lamp wait cause he completely
narcissistic,
like I don't give,
it doesn't even exist for him.
And so he's basically,
he's got tremendously well developed
psychopathic traits and he's also
delusional because he thinks this is all
going to be free.
So they go off the route of the main
culture out to an isolated place.
All right,
so it's like,
I would say that we're there going,
I told you that [inaudible] was a suburb
of the underworld.
Well that's where they're headed.
So,
and they're also in a mall,
not an easy thing
to escape.
One of the things that's quite striking
about horror movies is that they're
often,
they often feature clouds and they're
often said at amusement parks and you
might say,
well,
what,
what the hell is the connection between
the Amusement Park and horror?
Well,
I don't know if you've ever been to
amusement park,
but if you have,
you can see the connection pretty much
right away.
You know,
they,
it's,
it's mindless entertainment,
roughly speaking.
And now it's not like there's anything
particularly
intrinsically terrible about mindless
entertainment.
But there's this,
there's a dark side to amusement parks
and carney life and the gambling that
goes on there,
like it's low level.
It's a low level place.
It's a low class place roughly speaking
and it's because it's associated.
It's associated with this idea of fun in
the moment with no care for the future.
And that's its dark side.
That's the part of it is,
is it's tinted with horror and that's
what happens here.
These kids have abandoned culture.
They don't care about it at all.
They're cynical about it and no doubt
they have their reasons and they move.
They not only are they cynical about it,
but they even hate it.
Maybe it's being too tyrannical for them
or maybe they just don't want to bear
the responsibility of having to live up
to its demands.
In any case,
they moved from,
you know,
ceasing to identify with it,
to wanting to pull it down completely.
And they do that partly by engaging in
mindless entertainment.
But there's more to it than that.
And this is,
this is where the Nazi mob thing starts
to happen.
So you can't find your car chase in the
mall.
Now you see that center symbol that's a
Mandela niche.
It's very commonly portrayed in
cathedrals and the Mandela is the symbol
of the self from a union perspective.
And why that is is ridiculously
complicated,
but it's the best way that I could
describe it as like there's this
Buddhist idea that a lotus flower grows
up from the depths through the water and
then lays itself open on top.
And then the Buddha emerges in the
middle.
And that's what a Mandela is.
It's that flower process.
It's like emerging being manifesting
something perfect.
And that's that thing represents.
So
no,
all right,
I've been there.
And then you start to see what's going
on.
And like as I,
as I mentioned it at some point,
like remember what was happening in
Europe at the time that this movie was
being made.
You know,
like the dark forces of fascism were
really starting to gather,
you know,
in the movie is an unconscious dram of
sorts.
And one of the things that it's
suggesting is that there's a tight
connection between the abandonment of
individual moral responsibility.
The turning to deceit and the
degeneration of society into something
that's pleasure,
short term pleasure on the one hand that
absolute slavery and brutality on the
other.
And so you have this faceless figures
moving in the background,
locking the doors to begin with.
And it's all a conspiracy in some sense
to conspiracy by the coachman in order
to entrap the unwary
awesome themselves.
No.
So you know,
Pinocchio is become separated from his
conscience.
I would say that happens to lots of
people in,
in their teenage years.
You know,
they experiment with all sorts of things
they know they shouldn't be doing.
It's not a particularly pleasant life
and they lose the thread that guides
them.
Now there's some necessity in that
because in some sense they're wandering
through places that they need to
explore,
but it's also very dangerous because it
can leave you permanently damaged,
you know,
you can fall out and never get back on.
Okay,
so Pinocchio is in there and he's like
playing pool and smoking and drinking
and acting like a narcissist.
And this guy knows some cool tricks and
they're Pinocchio.
He takes a little swig of his cigar and
you know,
it makes him sick.
Right?
So there,
that's,
that's deceit right there,
right.
He's willing to falsify the nature of
his actual experience,
even at a deep physiological level in
order to impress this character
who,
you know,
was the last person in the world that
anyone sends a postcard to impress.
Okay.
And now he can't end.
Right.
Okay.
That's also very interesting.
You know,
you see the sideways eight ball and
that's a symbol of infinity and it's
starting to wander.
And you know,
partly what the,
partly what the images are suggesting
is,
first of all,
Pinocchio's aim is very unsteady because
he's pathologized himself and he's also
like,
he's facing an infinite number of
problems and can't aim straight to fix
them.
Losing your grip.
I also think that's pretty funny from
the perspective of teenage experience
because it's often the case that just
when some idiot teenager is out to
impress someone,
he or she shouldn't depressed,
that their conscience will pipe up and
they'll do something absolutely moronic
that you know,
makes them into a fool in front of the
people they're trying to impress.
And that's exactly what's happening
here.
You know,
and its partly because the person is
torn apart inside and can't act with any
strength.
Okay.
So anyways,
the cricket end,
this lamp put character have it out and
Pinocchio decides that he's going to go
with Lamp Wick and so Pinocchio storms
or the cricket storms out
and then
he's going home.
He's come on,
come on
and watch your neigh.
Okay,
Yo go
vegan ice.
Okay.
So basically what you see is that the
pathway that's been laid out so far
including this neurotic induced
antisocial trip to pleasure island
basically culminates in a form of
slavery.
But there's more to it than that because
it's voiceless slavery.
Right.
These kids,
they're now jack houses.
They're not fit to be slaves until they
can't speak properly anymore.
All they can do is break.
So they've severed their connection with
their capacity for genuine speech to
such a degree that everything that is
associated with a logo.
So let's say with the ability to think
things through and communicate,
that's all gone.
You're empty and brain and that's at
that point,
they're fit for slaves.
Yeah.
Well,
it's not only that he can't speak is,
is fit when you can no longer safe zone.
Right,
right,
right.
Absolutely.
That's right.
So that means that all of these
individual identity is gone as well.
There's nothing individual left at all.
There's just brute animal existence and
that's fit for slavery.
Oh,
mine,
next
door.
Maybe Allen
and Paul.
Yeah.
Okay.
So last notes are good
conch.
Okay.
You'd think something was done
or as you get to be a real board,
what do you think?
Okay,
sure.
Hey,
allow me
Brian.
Okay,
so the mirror,
of course,
that's the destruction of painful self
consciousness.
Oh,
Yay.
So the cricket knows what's going on and
he goes to Rescue Pinocchio.
And then the only way out from this
place is to dive into chaos.
So that's what happens.
They jump off the cliff,
very dangerous to get from somewhere
terrible to somewhere,
absolutely unknown.
And so they do that and they go home,
they wash up at home.
And so that's where we are now.
Well,
you can't go home again.
Okay,
so dad's not home.
It's too late.
And so now they have no idea what to do.
Going
now you'll see a weird intermingling of,
I would say pagan and Christian
Christian symbolism.
So the star now sends a dove and the
dove is a symbol of the holy ghost.
Right?
And hypothetically,
the Holy Ghost,
there's three members of the Christian
Trinity,
the father,
the son,
and the Holy Ghost.
And that's what the hell is a holy
ghost.
You know,
that's quite the weird idea.
But what it is,
what it is,
is it's a representation of the idea
that you have an image of the divine
within you and that it's something that
can,
it's something capable of communicating.
And so it's a natural force in part,
which is also why it's associated with
the blue fairy and this and this star.
It's,
well that's the best I can do at the
moment with that.
So anyways,
it gives the cricket a message from
beyond so to speak.
Hey,
it's a message pop
up.
It says here,
he um,
he went looking for you and uh,
uh,
he was one of them.
Okay.
So you noticed that,
you know,
Pinocchio without Japan it was lost,
but you pedo without Pinocchio gets
degenerates into chaos and it's
swallowed by a whale.
So the two are necessary for one another
anyways.
People swallow this part of the plot
without any problem.
And so the cricket now tells the puppet
that in order to become real,
he has to go to the bottom of the ocean
and rescue his father from a whale.
And so another part that makes
absolutely no sense.
So anyways,
that's what they proceed to do back into
the,
the cricket warns him about how
dangerous this is,
but decides to go along anyways.
So down they plunge into the ocean and
they have some kind of cute adventures
and they get the fish to tell them where
they're going.
But the Fisher so scared that they just
run away when they hear monster name.
And so notice that you know,
he's in the depths already and he has to
go to the darkest place in the depths in
order to find where his father is.
Okay.
Now Japan goes in there and he's
starving to death in the belly of a
whale.
There's not enough food,
there's not enough nourishment for him
to survive.
And he can't see any way that on his own
he can get out.
In fact,
he's actually given up.
Okay.
And he's fishing because he thinks,
well,
you know,
we might as well have some beat.
The whale wakes up and it catches a
bunch of fish,
but it also catches what you might
describe as king of the fish.
Now see that's Pinocchio.
So let's,
so this is where the movie gets varied.
I really have very difficult time
understanding how this symbolism got in
there.
But this whole part of the movie is
packed with fish symbolism.
And although you may know or you may
not,
but the fish was a symbol for it,
early Christianity and Christ is
assimilated to the fish.
There's all sorts of fish symbolism in
the new testament and there's all sorts
of reasons for that,
a number of which are truly
incomprehensible.
Some of the raster logical,
because
I won't even go into that.
So imagine this way,
you're somewhere starving
and you've got,
you've got two choices.
You can either figure out how to live so
that you're not going to be starving
anymore or you can catch some fish.
Okay.
So you can,
you can feed yourself momentarily or you
can feed yourself for the long run.
And so,
and people are making that choice all
the time.
And so you might say,
well,
if you're a good fisherman,
you catch a fish.
But if you're a really good fit from
fishermen,
you catch something from the depths that
feeds you all the time.
Okay.
So that's what's happening here.
Yup.
Oh he thought there was any relationship
with the Fisher and the Fisher king
cause you know yes,
definitely.
Yes,
absolutely.
definitely.
So,
okay,
so now Japan,
I was fishing like mad and he's happy
because he's catching fish now.
It's very cool what happens here because
Japan,
oh,
couches,
a bunch of fish.
Hypothetically he's looking for
Pinocchio.
But he says the unbusy catching fish
that when he catches Pinocchio he
doesn't even notice.
And then he kind of wakes up to the fact
that he's caught Pinocchio,
which is really what he's trying to
catch.
And when he turns around to hug him,
he grabs a fish and he kisses the fish
and then notices that it's not
Pinocchio.
So the filmmakers are very careful to
insist upon the fact that you peddle
becomes,
he's blinded by short term
considerations and cannot see when he's
caught the thing that's the most
valuable.
And we see why Pinocchio is the most
So this is actually the redemption of
Japan.
Oh,
to some degree,
he needs Pinocchio's youth and vision to
rescue himself from sterile,
sterile,
and static existence.
And that would be associated say with
the,
the construction of us,
a sterile totalitarian,
like North Korea,
where I think I told you last week,
the wise leader has told all the Koreans
that they better get used to sucking
routes like they did 20 years ago
because there ain't gonna be any food.
And not only that,
they get to donate to pounds of rice a
month each to the state warehouses,
which in principle are supposed to be
the places that distribute the food.
So the idea that a static enough state
can become sterile and baron is exactly
right.
So,
all right,
here's a mythological motif there and
many hero stories when the hero heroes
out to find the worst thing.
But when he finally finds it,
it's like he's out of there.
But by that time it's generally too
late.
You know?
So what it means to some degrees that no
matter how awful the thing that you're
looking for,
no matter how awful you think the thing
that you're looking for is,
it's more awful than you think.
Even prepared.
So Pinocchio,
he's out of their conscience too.
They're both gone.
Yeah.
Okay.
So Japan will basically tells Pinocchio
that there's no damn way they're getting
out of this whale.
And so Pinocchio has a bit of a
brainstorm.
Oh yeah.
Do you pay to also finds out that he's
half turned into a donkey,
which isn't all that pleasant.
He gets forgiven,
right?
Japan.
Oh,
says he's built a raft that they can get
out with,
but everything comes in and nothing goes
out in Pinocchio.
Decides that he could make the whale
sneeze and he does that.
So we'll start here.
He's got this brainstorm of an idea.
Okay.
Master of fire idea.
No,
not all offices
working comes.
Oh,
it's all British prenup.
Nice.
We cooked some of the fish.
Okay.
So that's a paradigm shift for Japan.
Oh,
the fire is there to cook the fish for
Pinocchio.
It's there to escape from the damn
whale.
Now,
the other thing that happens here is
Pinocchio sacrifices.
A bunch of things that you pedal thinks
are useful.
Japan will thinks he's going to be in
the whale.
I know.
Okay.
So now Pinocchio breaks up all the
furniture and builds a fire out of it.
And so he's,
you know,
when part of that is,
uh,
an explicit,
remind her that part of the reason that
the way people got out of the whale,
you know,
the terrible chaotic force of nature was
to master fire.
It's a technological,
it's a technological solution.
These are
not the chair.
Oh,
okay.
No.
So there's an idea there too that the
human use of technology is likely to
make the environment,
you know,
react terribly.
And we're all,
we're guilty about that all the time.
It's part of what underlies our
environmental guilt.
You know,
we're using technology against nature
and you know,
we always feel that there's going to be
a kickback,
we'd done something wrong,
there's going to be a kickback.
You know,
it's,
it's not like it's completely unfounded.
Okay.
So now the way home,
there's something bursty very
surprising,
which is that it transforms into a fire
breathing dragon.
Okay.
So then there's a great band
demand.
The whale just won't quit.
Need breaks their boat.
Altarpieces Pinocchio rescues his father
there
and then the is all smashed to pieces.
We'll pick up,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Japan.
Oh says save yourself right now.
He's out of the damn whale.
Why bother with the old mat?
That's a good question.
You know,
and because part of that question is,
well,
what's the relationship between the
individual and the culture?
What responsibility do you have to the
culture?
It's drowning.
It's not much use.
It's old.
It's,
it's,
it produced you.
It's worn out.
It's dangerous to rescue it.
Why bother?
Well,
Pinocchio decides to rescue his father.
So Pinocchio is basically peer destroyed
by the clash between no hell they should
chaos and insufficient culture.
And so as far as we know,
Japan,
it was alive.
Oh yeah.
So you know,
he sacrificed himself to save his
culture.
But you have,
you have to remember what he sacrificed.
He's a jackass,
puppet.
And maybe that is what's supposed to be
sacrificed.
If you're going to save your culture,
you know,
you get rid of the jackass.
Puppet is the really adopt the part of
the,
we want to have live anyways.
People identify with that.
They think,
oh,
that's me.
That's what I think.
That's who I am.
It's like,
well,
if you find yourself breaking,
you might presuppose that that's not
exactly the case.
Unselfish Aye.
Harmony is restored.
You can see that father and son Canal
dance together.
Okay.
Yeah.
And the car insurance is like finally
transformed at this point.
She was nice.
Hmm.
And now it's like a gold flower.
It's called Mandela.
It's the sun.
It's all those things.
And you see you can communicate with
this star.
No.
So all of that wrapped up in the Little
Kid's movie,
you know,
you can think about it.
There's the work of the collective
imagination.
And I mean that literally in some sense
because a huge number of people who are
creative worked on this,
you know?
And so it's constant compromises as to
plot and as to,
you know,
the images that are going to be used.
And like there's a tremendous amount of
attention and same amount of attention
focused on every single sale.
Right?
These things were hand painted.
So the amount of work that goes into
each frame is it's hours and hours and
hours of work and do each frame 60
frames a second cause Disney did it at
60 frames a second,
you know,
so,
and it's completely,
you know,
it's hard to remember when you watch
something like this that every single
bit of it was created,
you know?
And,
and by people who had to agree by genius
level people who had to agree on what
they were doing and so they'd feel their
way,
what seems right,
you know,
and the group would agree,
look,
that's the right thing.
Or someone would insist upon having had
done this particular way and the
narrative would emerge from that.
And someone had an intuition,
probably Disney,
that,
you know,
the Pinocchio Story had enough.
It's quite a bit transposed from the
colone story,
the original story.
But then it had enough depth,
you know,
to hang a story on it and to be worthy
of that much attention.
So,
and I think I like the developmental
path that it traces.
It's,
it's as accurately summarized in that
movie as I'd ever seen it summarized.
I mean,
the movie is not without its flaws.
I would say it kind of slips into
moralizing from,
you know,
from time to time.
Although,
you know,
I don't know if it's been done better.
So
you don't want to complain about it too
much.
Yeah.
So,
well one of the questions that we posed
at the beginning of the course was,
you know,
why do people do terrible things?
Why does societies degenerate?
In answer to that,
as far as I can tell,
is because people don't,
they people decide to not attend to
their knowledge of their own errors
or errors in the situation they find
themselves.
I think maybe it's,
they don't attend to their knowledge of
holes in being that might be a more
reasonable way of putting it.
And because they refuse to attend,
they allow the structure to get rotten
and they allow themselves to get weak.
And the more rotten the structure and
the weaker the people that compose it,
the more rapidly it degenerates,
the further rottenness and uh,
quickly or everything descends into
something that's absolutely horrified.
Hell for all intensive purposes.
And so the alternative to that out as
far as I can tell,
isn't so much specifically political as
it is psychological.
Although I think at this level of
analysis,
those two things merge,
you know,
you work on correcting the errors that
are accessible to you in your own life,
that you can correct and that you know
how to correct and simultaneously you
have the best chance of raw find your
culture and keeping,
you know,
the horrors of tyranny and an unbridled
nature at bay.
You know,
and I would also say that's the
fundamental human story.
We've been working on that story for our
entire evolutionary history.
And so maybe it's wrong,
but that's the one we've based our
survival law.
And you know,
there's always the possibility that it's
not wrong.
That's it guys.
Nice talking to you.